die apfel streuselkuchen richtig geismar
zitat ist ja was für dezember wie siehst
du das ja ich auch
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
veganen apfel streuselkuchen vom blech
mit dinkelmehl und wenn ihr mögt ohne
raffinierten zucker ich lese eure
kommentare ich schaue immer wieder an
was so gewünscht ist und viele fragen
wirklich nach veganen rezepten ich finde
wenn vegan dann muss es auch wirklich
lecker sein und ohne dass man denken ja
ist vegan ist okay deswegen schmeckt das
irgendwie nicht besonders gut nein es
kann auch wirklich super lecker sein ich
habe letztens erst eine vegane
schokotorte auf dem kaufland kanal
gemacht verlege ich auch gerne und in
der infobox schaut sich gerne an aber
wir machen heute einen apfel
streuselkuchen so dafür lege ich direkt
los mit meinem boden es wird ein veganer
mit boden ich nehm dinkelmehl da kann
nämlich auch oft die nachfrage ob ich
mal was mit dinkel machen kann
dinkelmehl typ 630 kann man eigentlich
genau eins zu eins austauschen wenn ihr
rezepte mit mehl typ 405 habt da gebe
ich jetzt vegane butter mit dazu und ich
benutze heute satte zucker die mag ich
ganz gerne und damit ihr jetzt auch den
mürbeteig richtig schön fest bekommt und
zu einem geschmeidigen teig verkneten
könnt brauchen wir noch etwas kaltes
wasser und habe ich schon gesagt habe
ich bin ich ich verliebe mich auf jeden
fall alle ganz genau wenn man da unten
in die infobox
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt den mürbeteig direkt
in meinen back raum gegeben dann habe
ich eingestellt auf 26 mainz habe ich
schon wieder vergessen hat dass jetzt 26
x 30 cm
ich habe jetzt auch mal eingelocht das
backblech genommen ihr könnt auch ein
normales backblech nehmen aber hier habt
ihr dann einfach wirklich ein richtig
mürbeteig da ist ein bisschen schwerer
zu verteilen als weniger drin wenn macht
aber gar nichts nach dem backen wird es
einfach richtig lecker hatte er schon
mal ausprobiert mit zur familie genommen
und der war restlos verputzt ich mach
jetzt direkt weiter so das gebe ich kurz
zur seite der boden ist ja hier schon
fertig und damit ich mir ein bisschen
geschirr sparen nämlich jetzt einfach
die gleiche schüssel und wir machen
jetzt schon die streusel da kommen
eigentlich auch wieder fast die gleichen
zutaten reinig nehmen die der veganer
butter dann habe ich weder dinkelmehl
diesmal brauchen wir kein wasser
allerdings wieder satte zucker und
diesmal auch rohrzucker mit dabei weil
das einfach geschmack richtern deshalb
passiert sei wie gesagt ausprobiert mit
dem rohrzucker hat es mir richtig gut
geschmeckt und david zucker kommt
manchmal das ist ganz normal nimmt ihn
dann einfach so in die hände und treibt
es rein und dinkelmehl schmeckt ja
manchmal so richtig gesund also wenn ihr
rein weist solche wenn ihr dinge
vollkommen ihr benutzt dann es schmeckt
einfach gesund und ich meine dass so ein
bisschen im negativen sinne dass man
sich auf ein stück kuchen freut und dann
ist es so ganz komischer geschmack aber
bei dem normalen dinkelmehl typ 630
braucht euch da keine sorgen machen also
ich finde es ist kaum ein unterschied
zum normalen mehr was ihr halt so zum
backen verwendet
[Musik]
der boden wird jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für zwölf minuten vor
gebacken
[Musik]
der boden des reggae die streusel sind
fertig und jetzt kommt unser marzipan
zum einsatz hatte keinen marzipan fans
seid dann könnt ihr auch jetzt an der
stelle einfach marmelade nehmen ihr
könnt auch meine tschira laden nämlich
ist ja auch mit der süße und mit
sparsamen eingelegt worden hat auch
keinen zuckerzusatz habe ich hab nichts
da wollen wir das von weil er mal
geklaut wurde gibt das nämlich total
aber ich mag marzipan ganz gerne und
schneit denn jetzt hier in so ganz feine
scheiben
es gibt auch zuckerfreien marzipan
deshalb hatte ich das anfangs erwähnt
wenn ihr mögt komplett ohne raffinierten
zucker ich habe jetzt hier im normale
marzipanrohmasse
aber ich kann mir auch wirklich diesem
zuckerfreien marzipan mal ganz gut darin
vorstellen und das ist natürlich
vollkommen euch überlassen sobald ich
das erledigt habt kommt es direkt auf
den boden und ich bereite schon unsere
äpfel vor indem es die scheele und in
kleine stückchen schneiden
eigentlich schon auch also ich finds so
geht's schneller aber eigentlich könnte
man denn auch raspeln man könnte ihn
überraschend in die steuerung ist auch
geil
[Musik]
zu den äpfeln könnt ihr jetzt wenn ihr
mögt noch ein bisschen zeit geben ich
finde das passt ganz gut egal welche
jahreszeit wir haben so das werde ich
jetzt hier noch ein bisschen arbeiten
dann kommen die äpfel quasi auf die
marzipan schicht und darüber dann die
streusel und dann wird der blechkuchen
zu ende gegangen noch ein kleiner tipp
wenn ihr mögt dann nimmt gerne
säuerliche äpfel ich finde die passen
geschmacklich am besten ich habe euch
ein paar sorten in die infobox
[Musik]
und jetzt packen wir ihn bei gleicher
temperatur für 35 minuten zu ende
[Musik]
ok
dabei hätten besser ist das ist ja auch
klassenzimmer leer
[Gelächter]
ich bin bereit ich freue mich richtig
darauf den vor einer woche gemacht
ganzen stiefel streuselkuchen und
[Musik]
damit gut
geschmeckt hat anders man sieht hier
kann es vielleicht nochmal ran kommt
kann man ihr diese marzipan schicht ich
weiß nicht was braucht es
richtig konzipiert ist ja mal was für
dezember leute ihr könnt gerne durch
auch mal in den anderen monaten marzipan
benutzen wie siehst du das ja ich auch
richtig voll also richtig gute
kombination aus äpfeln marzipan teufeln
dass wenn man vor so richtig liegen wird
guten morgen ich hatte den vor einer
woche mit bei hansas familie und haben
wir fanden richtig lecker so ob ich
nicht
genau wissen und haben wir nichts übrig
gelassen haben ein ganzes welche
mitgenommen und der war komplett
von den lecker einschließlich der
zahnarzt der familie weil da ist ja
immer so für
und einfach da für zucker drin und jetzt
kommt der oberhammer ich glaube muss es
so verrückt machen ich heiße es nicht
auch weil ich der vegan also du hast mir
das glück des gehörs ich wusste das
nicht ich habe das noch nicht raus genau
das ist das ziel das man das nicht
unbedingt raus schmeckt also ich wünsche
euch viel spaß um nach wacken und hoffe
dass ihr dem video ein bäumchen nach
oben da lassen wenn euch das rezept
gefallen hat dann sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten mal wieder
[Musik]